with the Vista like this the worries of
brexit seem a long way from the Spanish
coastline but for hundreds of thousands
of Britons they are very real indeed
concerns in the town of me has about
rights jobs and for the elderly in the
expat population about health care for
the 18 years Josephine Sykes has lived
here she's been able to access free
medical treatment as an EU citizen
she says Theresa May has to push for
that to continue main thing I think is
the medical especially when we get in as
old as I am but if they stop it all
together it's going to be a bit of a
problem because like I said at my age
having private insurance I wouldn't be
able to afford it Josephine's concerns
are replicated many times over in a
country which acts as the main draw for
Brits wanting to relocate more than
three hundred thousand expats live in
Spain and a third of that population is
over 65 some here are told us they won't
be able to stay if the system changes
could an unintended consequence of
brexit be a flow of people to the UK not
new migrants from across Europe but
Brits migrating back resources like
hospitals housing and for Danielle
Garcia schools the single mum moved to
Spain with her family three years ago
for now her children who were born into
the EU get access to local education for
what guarantee for the future to be
living at the moment in fear of what's
going to happen and not knowing is isn't
comfortable at all you know I'm already
having to think what do I need to put in
place in order to keep my life here lack
of clarity is bothering not just the
British here but locals in a town where
the expat influence on the local economy
is everywhere from restaurants to the
barbers and the nail salon Brits are
running businesses renting or owning
space offering services
no surprise then that the local mayor is
pushing hard to maintain the rights of
UK citizens in Spain portmanteau l peso
get the weight of the british community
here in Mijas is very important so
important that we're economically
dependent on them they are neighbors
like everyone else obviously but they
add to the economy and it is their
contribution which leaves many
optimistic that a deal will be done not
just for British people here in Europe
but Europeans in the UK the expats need
Spain and Spain really likes having them
here Michele Clifford Sky News me Hasan
the Costa del Sol